et l'union européenne va limiter les
exportations de masquer d'autres
équipements médicaux de protection afin
de garantir son propre approvisionnement
face à la pandémie due nouveau
coronavirus pour en parler
nous sommes maintenant avec gerald
cardiaque médecin urgentiste un bonsoir
à vous merci de réagir en direction arte
france d'abord ce chiffre qui vient de
tomber c'est un nouveau record de décès
en italie en 24 heures 368 décès en 24
heures c'est un nouveau record jour est
votre réaction par rapport à ce chiffre
on voit que l'épidémie elle progresse en
italie a malgré les mesures de
confinement après il faudrait regarder
en détail qui sont ces gens décédés
encore une fois donné des données brutes
comme ça de décès vous savez en france
chaque jour
koror coronavirus bien sûr il ya 1700
décès par jour donc il faut toujours
aller recontextualiser si on voit que
les noms le nombre de décès augmente en
revanche en italie malgré les mesures de
confinement
ça veut dire que leur système de santé
et peut-être toujours à saturation et ça
nous engage encore plus et c'est ce qui
nous a fait j'allais dire accéléré voir
changer d'avis ou en tout cas modérés
notre discours depuis quelques semaines
en voyant ce qui se passe en italie
il faut clairement qu'on se prépare à la
même chose que nos voisins italiens
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que nous
aussi on doit se préparer à être dépassé
par à cette crise du coronavirus dépassé
faute de moyens pour les hôpitaux
publics
alors quand on regarde les chiffres de
mortalité ils sont à peu près 2 entre 0
1% et 1 % le problème c'est que parmi
les patients qui seront affectés ont dit
c'est 99 % vont guérir c'est vrai mais
même si vous n'avez quand % de malades
qui vont avoir besoin de réanimation
mais que vous avez à ce qu'on appelle un
taux d' attaque c'est à dire énormément
de personnes dans la population 15
millions pendant cette hypothèse-là 15
millions jean michel blanquer remise
d'éducation nationale a parlé lui de la
moitié donc de 50% des français dont 30
millions mais prenant cette hypothèse
basse de 15 millions 1 % qui nécessite
de la réanimation sur 15 millions ça
fait cent cinquante mille personnes qui
ont besoin de réanimation or nos
capacités leçon de 15000 places en
réanimation ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on pourrait prendre un dixième
des patients en charge
d'où la stratégie du gouvernement depuis
le début de cette crise de freiner de
ralentir d'aplatir cette vague qui
risque de submerger pour cette vague
puisse passer plusieurs semaines sur
plusieurs mois éventuellement pour
pouvoir lisser les choses et que ces 150
mille malades si on part sur 7 y pose à
l'hypothèse l'appui savoir tous une
place en réanimation
si vous les prenez tous la même semaine
vous n'aurez pas la place si vous les
prenez sur une dizaine de semaines
on peut espérer pouvoir absorber ce flux
de patients vous avez entendu cette
annonce
de l'union européenne sur la limitation
des exportations de masques
d'équipements médicaux
beaucoup d'annoncés tous azimuts
concernant justement les moyens qu'il
faut donner au système de santé
votre regard là-dessus il ya deux choses
la stratégie qu'on vient de dire qui est
de freiner l'arrivée des malades et la
deuxième partie a mais les deux sont
concomitantes c'est évidemment préparé
les hôpitaux c'est de libérer des lits
libérer des places de réanimation voir
où sont les places disponibles et à quel
moment on va pouvoir monter en puissance
franchisés conte à 15 mille lits de
réanimation à peu près on en a cinq
mille on a sept mille lits de soins
intensifs qui peuvent être mobilisés et
puis on a quelques respirateur qui
peuvent monter en puissance et c'est
tout l'enjeu des plans blancs dans les
hôpitaux qui maintenant depuis quelques
jours pour le territoire national mais
quelques semaines pour la région grand
test permettent de monter en puissance
progressivement et puis faut pas penser
qu réanimation je suis dans un hôpital
qui s'appelle l'hôtel-dieu cas délicat
délit qui peuvent être réouvert
extrêmement rapidement une centaine de
lits et bien il faut prendre dans toutes
les régions de france ces mesures là de
façon à pouvoir réarmer des hôpitaux qui
pourront accueillir les malades
peut-être libéré des places de
réanimation une fois que les malades
dans un petit peu mieux mais pas
suffisamment pour rentrer à la maison où
les malades les moins graves ou tout
simplement des malades qui ne sont pas
corona positif mais qui ont un infarctus
ou qui ont des problèmes de santé hautes
qui nécessitent une hospitalisation
et puis après il ya la question des
moyens des masques c'est fondamental de
protéger les soignants parce que ça va
être le maillon faible là aussi du
système gallery mais il ya aussi des
soignants parce que si vous mettez au
tapis si vous mettez parterre d'emblée
des soignants qui sont les plus à risque
puisqu'ils sont en contact je sors de
garde on est en contact avec des gens en
permanence il faut qu'ils aient des
masques donc c'est clair que les masques
ça devient une denrée rare c'est clair
qu'il faut les réserver
plutôt à nos troupes soignante en france
on se posera la question fera le retour
d'expérience après pourquoi des stocks
ont été envoyées ou n'ont pas été
constituée en tout cas pour l'instant je
pense que c'est la priorité et il faut
que tout le monde aille dans le même
sens est-ce qu'on va y arriver gerald 15
actes parce qu'on entend beaucoup de
médecins beaucoup de son de cloche sur
des médecins qui sont en colère aussi
alors on est sur des hypothèses les
médecins sont en colère notamment les
libéraux parce qu'il dise on n'a pas
deux mais on n'a pas de masque donc ça
c'est un vrai problème et encore une
fois il faudra revenir après la crise
sur pourquoi comment qui et c'est là on
est dans un objectif de mobilisation
maximale de tous les services de santé
et de mobilisation maximale de tout un
chacun parce que les mesures qui sont de
se laver les mains ça paraît idiot à
dire mais se laver les mains
être à distance d'autres personnes
limité ses transports et pourquoi pas un
confinement à l'italienne ou à la
chinoise dans les quelques heures ou
dans les quelques jours ce sont les
moyens de ne pas transmettre le virus à
son prochain à un autre individu c'est
pour soi et c'est pour l'ensemble de la
société et l'histoire de la barrière de
70 ans qui a été un peu par le président
la république me comme les plus de 70
ans sont les plus à risques c'est vrai
ils sont plus à risque mais c'est pas
parce qu'on a moins de soixante dix ans
c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas de maladie
sévère chronique invalidante qu'il faut
pas prendre ces mesures très au sérieux
c'est l'ensemble des individus en france
et partout en europe et partout dans le
monde et j'allais dire qu'ils doivent
appliquer ces gestes barrière c'est pas
une histoire de plus ou moins de 70 ans
tout le monde doit les appliquer pour
soi et encore une fois la bonne nouvelle
est pour répondre à votre votre
interrogation est ce qu'on va y arriver
on va tout faire pour y arriver à la
fois pour juguler l'épidémie enrayer la
transmission si ces mesures de distance
sociale
et puis on va tout faire pour préparer
le système de santé et les deux choses
concomitante vont permettre de lisser
d'amortir le choc après je suis pas
demain j'ai pas ma boule de cristal
on a beaucoup changé ces dernières
semaines en envoyant cette vague
arrivait de chine on pensait que c'était
un problème chine aussi nos chinois on
s'est aperçu que c'est arrivé en italie
rapidement on a mis en oeuvre un certain
de choses et puis vous savez on apprend
tous les jours et notamment en marchant
avec un virus qui nous fait découvrir
des choses est la durée d'incubation
elle n'est pas si clair que ça le mode
de transmission ils sont pas si clair
que ça non plus donc tout ça fait qu'il
faut qu'on évolue et surtout qu'on est
si possible un temps d'avancé par un
temps de retard et juste cette dernière
question gérard cazaux qu'on n'a plus
beaucoup de temps 50 à 70% de la
population qui sera touchée par le
coroner et russes selon ge
michel blanc terre il faut pas s'alarmer
ces coûts sont quand même des chiffres
anxiogènes
c'est anxiogène si on pense que d'être
le virus vous touche vous mourrez c'est
pas du tout le cas encore une fois 90 2
99% de la population contaminée par le
virus va s'en sortir parfois même sans
aucun symptôme et c'est ça qui est très
perturbant pour la population se dit
mais alors c'est un virus n'est pas
dangereux s'il est dangereux non pas par
sa virulence ou sa gravité individuelle
mais par le petit pourcentage de
personnes qui présentent des
complications mais ce petit pourcentage
sur un an semble énorme de populations
touchées c'est là où ces petits
pourcentages devient deviennent de
grands nombres de malades qu'il faut
qu'il faut prendre en charge dont je ne
sais pas si c'est 15% à 30% 50% de la
population qui sera touché mais de toute
façon la population allaient toucher l
s'immunise moi je suis persuadé que les
chiffres qui sont égrainés tous les
jours sont largement deux salles la
réalité et ça c'est pas si inquiétant
que ça puisque ça veut dire que beaucoup
ont été touchés sans s'en rendre compte
et sont immunisés le vrai problème c'est
que si le chiffre de 1000 se multiplient
et continuer à augmenter de manière
exponentielle pas mathématiquement il y
aura un petit pourcentage qui fait que
si le chiffre se multiplient pas ce
petit pourcentage encore une fois ça
sera beaucoup de monde à accueillir dans
les urgences où les services de
réanimation
merci beaucoup gerald quinzaine pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin urgentiste merci